One of the reasons why computer security
is so hard is because you have to get
absolutely everything right in order to
have a secure system.
And there's lots of different kinds of
things you can get wrong.
Everything from your software was Buggy,
your passwords were too weak,
you publish your passwords accidentally,
your hardware was insecure,
they user made a mistake and fell victim
to a phishing attack and gave their
credentials to,
uh,
a foreign agent or a bad guy,
right?
All of those things have to be done
correctly in order to have a secure
system,
right?
It might seem tempting to think in,
everybody has a cell phone,
so you could just use your cell phone to
do voting like we do for American idol
or similar TV shows.
It works for American idol because
nobody cares all that much who wins or
doesn't win.
If you get the wrong outcome,
some people will care,
but it won't affect sort of the future
of the country,
for example.
Um,
it's not sensible to use cell phones for
voting for things that matter.
National elections,
for example,
because the software on a phone is
enormous and very complicated.
And so understanding that that code is
correct and actually counting all of the
votes appropriately would be a task that
would be,
it's so complex is to be infeasible.
You could have,
you know,
the legitimate APP that it is designed
to correctly count the votes for an
election,
but somebody could hack into that set of
applications and,
and,
and plant bugs in a bunch of different
cell phones so that the final results
were,
uh,
not the actual intent didn't actually
capture the intensive all the voters.
So a system for voting that relies
entirely on computers to do all of the
voting will never be secure because
you'll never have enough confidence that
the code that was running on those
computers correctly,
cow counted the votes as the person who
voted intended.
There's always the chance that there
were bugs or that a hacker came and
changed the code or a corrupted the code
to make the result be what the hacker
wanted instead of what the voters
wanted.
Um,
so one of the things to know about how
the U s election system works is that
voting machines are the purview of
states.
So every state has their own process for
deciding how,
what technology to use to count votes.
And so it's not that there's not a
monoculture where every single votings
site has the same technology.
It's determined on a state by state
basis.
So you have 50 different state
authorities at least who were deciding
what technology to use on for that
particular state.
And there are different technologies in
play.
One of the technologies is just a
touchscreen where you go when you tap
the choices that you want and it records
it in the computer program.
10 states currently have that kind of
technology,
and from a cybersecurity perspective
that technology is terrible because what
computers do is exactly what they're
told to do by the last person who loaded
code onto the system.
I think people who don't know very much
about computers tend to think that
computers do the right thing,
but in fact they just do exactly what
they're told to do.
So if they're told to do the correct
thing by a person who has the authority
to tell them,
then that's great.
But that's often not what happens.
The voting systems that just have the
touch screen,
there's no way of auditing what happened
retroactively.
It just a question of,
you know,
did the system actually counted
correctly?
You don't know.
All you have at the end of the day is
the collection of,
of totals.
So somebody could have replaced the
code,
hacked in and made it count in a
slightly skewed way,
in a very skewed way.
You really have no way of telling.
So that technology is bad.
People pretty much know that technology
is bad and it's being phased out.
So no one is trying to buy more of these
machines at this point and they're no
longer being manufactured.
So we're trending in a good direction as
far as that's concerned.
Um,
a different kind of machine or the
optical scanning machines where you fill
out,
it's kind of like a scan tron form from
elementary school where you fill out the
multiple choice questions on the form
and then the form is read electronically
and now the program that's doing the
reading has all the problems of the
system that I talked about before where
it is software that scanning and
counting and could be buggy,
could be corrupted by somebody who's
hacking in,
but you still have that paper records so
you can go back after the fact and audit
to confirm that the report that the
amount,
the total that was reported was actually
the correct and so that that post facto
audit and capability is really
important.
Most states use this technology.
Now some states have in place an
automatic auditing process,
so independent of whether any candidate
asks for an audit,
they go and pick some number of the
voting districts and some number of the
ballots and they checked to make sure
that the counting process was correct.
I think probably the level of auditing
isn't sufficient.
There needs to be broader auditing and
more random auditing going on,
but it's definitely a step in the right
direction.
The principle that people in this who
work in this area talk about is they
want to make sure that they can
guarantee the results are correct,
even if a nefarious person wrote the
code that did the counting.
So it has to work,
even if the software was completely
buggy.
And this,
uh,
optical scanning reading technology
satisfies that characteristic because
even if the code that does the fit,
the counting of the scan tron form is
buggy.
They can go look at the physical forms
and figure out that there was a mistake
and correct it using different software.
So there an audibility capability that
exists in that,
that kind of technology that doesn't
exist if you have no paper trail.
So I think at this point we kind of know
how to do it.
And from a tactical point of view,
and the question is getting the states
all to shift to that new kind of
technology.
Hmm.
Yeah.